[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen in meine taten welt
heute gibt es von mir eine torte mit
zitronen garage und lemon card diese
torte wenig später mit von dann
überziehen und mit blüten passte und 1
stritt klasse dekorieren die torte
schmeckt aber auch ganz gut oder von
dort und ohne deco ihr könnt sie nämlich
dann auch ganz einfachen weg sollen dort
umfallen und etwas scheu so oder so
dekorieren
ihr könnt aber auch zum beispiel ein
paar zitronenscheiben einkochen wie bei
meinen skulpturen video das sich aus dem
swat tal magazin gemacht habe darunter
viele eben immer wissen wollen wie ich
meine torten glattstreichen und mit von
dort über ziele zeige ich euch dass in
diesem video
die kombination zitrone und von dort
finde ich auch ziemlich lecker da ist
mir nämlich dann der belag nicht so süß
denn bei anderen tropfen wie zum
beispiel der schoko bananen torte es
sich denn von dort manchmal nur mit wenn
er nicht so dick ausgerollt ist aber
meistens sicher mir einfach viel zu süß
und das hauptproblem habe ich bei dieser
zitronen torte einfach nicht weil die
torte einfach leichter die schmeckt und
stammt die kombination mit dem schießen
von damit wirklich gut dazu passen
ich plane so torten ja im vornherein
immer wie ich sie aufbauen und wie ich
sie dann eben zeitlich organisiere ich
habe dazu schon einen noch beitrag
geschrieben den verlegte ich euch hier
unter dem video und werde ich euch erst
einmal zeigen wie ich den ruhetag
herstelle und was ihr an zutaten
benötigt ich werde den kuchen in einer
20 zentimeter spielform machen oder das
ist die menge für diese springform dafür
braucht ihr drei eier 100 gramm
puderzucker und ihr braucht flüssigkeit
insgesamt 80 milliliter
ich nehme dazu jetzt 30 milliliter
frisch gepressten zitronensaft und 50
milliliter eierlikör statistik es könnte
ja auch mineralwasser nehmen oder andere
liköre oder aromen
ihr braucht 60 gramm öl etwas ab
geriebener zitronenschale 75 g
speisestärke 75 gramm mehl und eine
halbe
packung backpulver das sind etwa sieben
bis acht gramm wie immer werden jetzt
zuerst die eier mit dem puderzucker
verrührt und das macht ihr so lange bis
sie weiß schau mich an
[Musik]
wenn ihr dann eine schöne cremige masse
habt bekommen jetzt einfach die
restlichen zutaten dazu mail und
speisestärke vermische ich da kommt auch
backpulver rein und dann gebt ihr
einfach alle zutaten hier mit dazu
und das wird jetzt alles einmal ganz
kurz ein gerührt auf nur in niedrigster
stufe
[Musik]
wenn noch mal kurz alles auch
durchrühren ich habe ich meine 20 cm
form schon vorbereitet da würde ich den
teig jetzt einfach ein teig jetzt bei
170 grad gebacken
so sieht der kuchen jetzt direkt nach
dem backen aus bei mir hat 30 minuten
bei 175 grad gebraucht jetzt werde ich
den ganz kurz abdecken fünf minuten
stehen lassen und dann löse ich ihn aus
der form heraus
[Musik]
so las ich dann kuchen jetzt einmal
komplett auskühlen damit er beim
abkühlen nicht austrocknet lediglich ein
leicht feuchtes küchentuch außen herum
werden der kundin abkühlt wenn die
auszeit nutzen und eure füllungen
klarstellen wie bereits am anfang
erwähnt werde ich eine zitronengras
herstellen und einen ländern karte ich
habe euch jetzt schon oft genug gezeigt
wie man danach erstellt dazu habe ich
auch ein eigenes video das werde ich
euch hier unten als video am tropf
posten da könnt ihr euch das noch einmal
genau anschauen
ich werde es nämlich im nächsten schritt
etwas kürzer halten euch nur ganz kurz
zeigen wie das geht und was ihr eben an
zutaten braucht aus 200 gramm sahne und
400 gramm weiße schokolade werde ich
jetzt die ghanas herstellen
in meinem video habe ich das euch
bereits gezeigt ich mache das jetzt ganz
schnell im thermomix gibt dazu einfach
die sahne in der mixed hof werde die
sahne in zwei minuten bei 100 grad
aufkochen und zum verfeinern benutze ich
hier noch etwas zitronensäure die gibt
es so in pulverform zu kaufen auf
türkisch heißt es lieber so viele kennen
das nur vom putzen kann ja ganz gut mit
zitronensäure entkalken aber man kann es
eben auch als lebensmittel benutzen das
ist der lebensmittel sei dank
und ich werde noch etwas zitronenschale
benutzen ich nehme immer bio zitrone
wenn ich den obi zitronen habe habe ich
die schale art ihr könnt die auch ganz
gut einfrieren und dann bei bedarf
benutzen wenn die samen aufgekocht ist
konnte schokolade wein dann muss man
aufpassen dass alles schön bedeckt ist
und so lasse ich das jetzt etwa zwei bis
drei minuten stehen
nach 23 minuten hat sich dann die
schokolade aufgelöst dann wird es auch
stufe 4 etwa 10 bis 20 sekunden
durchgeführt und jetzt gebt ihr nach
belieben zitronensäure und zitronen
schadet dazu ich würde mit einem
teelöffel zitronensäure anfangen und
dann könnt ihr ja je nach dem etwas mehr
nehmen und zitronenschale gebe ich mal
so zwei prisen rein oder bisschen mehr
den rest kann man wie gesagt einfrieren
noch mal ganz kurz auf stufe vier
verrühren und so sieht es dann aus
das finde ich mir jetzt in eine andere
schüssel um und stellt das über nacht in
den kühlschrank und kann es morgen dann
schön abgekühlt weiterverwenden
die gar schluss jetzt gut abkühlen
und da ich den kuchen im test morgen
befinden werde ich habe jetzt einfach so
zeitlich aufgeteilt dass ich heute nicht
so viel arbeit habe da ich den leben
jetzt erst mal gefunden werde werde ich
die garage in den kühlschrank stellen
dann müsst ihr aber darauf achten dass
die garage später beim verarbeiten nicht
so kalt ist das heißt ihr nehmt sie dann
am besten zwei drei stunden vor der
zubereitung wieder aus dem kühlschrank
die lässt sich nämlich am besten
verarbeiten wenn sie so eine konsistenz
den nutella hat falls ihr den kuchen am
gleichen tag bestreichen volt eignet
sich das wirklich gute ihr stellt die
garage kühlschrank zum abkühlen und
sobald sie so um die 20 grad hat könnte
ich sie wieder verwendeten werde ich die
garage abkühlt
werde ich schon einmal die zweite
erfüllung zu bereiten die habe ich
bisher noch nie gemacht das ist ein
level körpers gehört ist eine
zitronencreme aus großbritannien
die benutzten die dauert meistens als
brotaufstrich oder als füllung für
leckere kuchen für muffins und auch zum
beispiel zum tee den sie dort mittags
jeden tag trinken
wie gesagt langem gehört habe ich bisher
noch nie selber gemacht ich hatte nur
mal probiert mir nicht schmeckt ist
natürlich ziemlich gut ich bin ja
zitrone lief aber ich werde dazu jetzt
das thermomix rezept benutzen werde
jetzt erstmal nur die halbe menge machen
weil ich einfach nicht weiß ob es gut
funktioniert oder ob es mir überhaupt so
schmeckt und was ihr dazu haben sie da
und mit dem zeige ich euch jetzt
dafür braucht ihr 250 gramm butter 185
gramm zucker bei esslöffel geriebene
zitronenschale und 65 gramm zitronensaft
jetzt kommen alle zutaten zusammen in
den mix topf
der deckel bleibt jetzt weg und so wird
das etwa 17 minuten bei 90 grad auf
stufe 2 gekuschelt
danach sieht die masse dann so aus ist
also deutlich eingedeckt jetzt wird sie
noch mal 25 sekunden auf stufe sechs
verrührt diesmal aber mit messbecher
damit nichts raus spritzt so sieht es
danach aus
schüler vom topfdeckel weg kratzen
ich nehme mir dann schraubt lästert die
habe ich vorher jetzt mit heißem wasser
ausgespült und da kommt jetzt dieses
lernen gehört hinein reicht es auch ein
bisschen ich habe nur die halbe menge
gemacht um es mal auszuprobieren
der deckel drauf und wenn ihr das jetzt
länger haltbar machen wollt einfach
umdrehen und so lagern bis es abkühlt so
bildet sich nämlich ein vakuum und dann
bleibt das ziemlich lange frisch ich
habe mir vorher schon gedacht dass die
zuckermenge etwas zu viel ist ich habe
das ländern kalt jetzt probiert mir
persönlich
es ist ein tick zu süß ich werde beim
nächsten mal etwa ein drittel weniger
zucker nehmen mein mann zum beispiel
macht es ganz süß dann müsst ihr einfach
selber probieren wie ihr euch das eben
besser schmeckt lang art ist in diesen
kleinen marmeladengläsern auch eine
super geschenkidee das hält sich auch
ein paar wochen und kann man schön
dekorieren und einpacken und wie gesagt
könnt ihr das eben nicht nur für diese
zitronen torte benutzen sondern auch als
brotaufstrich als muffin füllung oder
für diverse andere kuchen und als
nächstes zeige ich euch jetzt einmal wie
man den kuchen auf schneidet wie man
ihnen füllt und dann auch wie man ihnen
bescheinigt
ich habe jetzt hier mal einen kuchen
den hab ich gestern noch in diese
kuchenformen gegeben damit er nicht
austrocknet
der ist schön saftig hier habe ich die
garage die weiten danach dem kühlschrank
sie ist jetzt noch etwas zu kalt zum
aufschlagen ich werde jetzt mal hier
stehen lassen und hier habe ich noch
dieses lemon gehört das ist jetzt so ein
festes gelee wie so eine art putting bei
der ghana spielen wir ganz deutlich
sehen dass sie wirklich steinhart
geworden ist ich werde jetzt deswegen
damit ich sie eben besser aufschlagen
kann
ganz kurz in der mikrowelle geben bei
niedrigster stufe
wäre es nicht machen wollt lasst sie
einfach eine stunde bei zimmertemperatur
etwas von der temperatur unterkommen und
ich mache das jetzt ganz kurz und zeigt
dann ist es in etwa so und es schlage
ich jetzt einmal ganz kurz dem
handrührgerät auf
[Musik]
wirklich nur ganz leicht das stelle ich
kurz zur seite und kümmere mich so lange
um den kuchen
den werde ich jetzt in drei booten
einteile
am rand einfach ansetzen
[Musik]
dann nehme ich mir hier so eine platte
das ist jetzt kein muss ich sage euch
jetzt nur wie ich das immer mache das
ist eine leicht schaum platte eine
charta platte die ist 5 mm breit die
kaufe ich immer online bei www
architektur bedarf de und staat setze
ich dann meinen untersten tortenboden
drauf und kann dann so die torte immer
auch mal auf die hand nehmen und auch
ganz gut stapeln
dafür müsst ihr jetzt natürlich die
platte zurechtschneiden in der größe
wird der tortenboden ist ihr könnt jetzt
einfach hergehen und den tortenboden
einfach ausmessen mit einem tortenring
und dann hier einmal abmessen
dann nehme ich mir ganz einfach im stift
und markieren den kreis von ihnen so und
das tolle ist hier auch dass man diese
platte ganz einfach mit seinem kater
ausschneiden kann ich lege mir einfach
ein wolf rap darunter und kann dann
einfach der linie entlang schneiden
[Musik]
dann kann man hier einfach aus trennen
und hat mir kleine tortenplatte mit dem
es die jetzt auch großartig gar nichts
machen
ich nehme dir jetzt die kuli strich ist
in auf der seite deswegen habe ich es
lieber um dann gehe ich auf nummer
sicher dass da auch nichts dran hängen
bleibt
da kommt bei mir jetzt einfach etwas von
dieser ganz oben drauf gerade so ein
bisschen zum ankleben auch an den
rändern und so kann die torte später
auch nicht mehr verrutschen die hält ein
echt bombenfest
da kommt jetzt der erste boden drauf
wichtig ist dass die platte möglichst
etwas kleiner ist als eure torte also
lieber ein bisschen zu klein als zu groß
also hier ist etwas zu groß ist schneide
ich jetzt kurz weg also lieber jetzt
exakt arbeiten
dann nehme ich mir einfach meine kuchen
platte streich gleich mal etwas von
diesen namen card drauf achtet man nicht
zu viel da ist ja so ein bisschen zu fuß
war aber ich sehe die kräftige gelbe
farbe also das ist schon toll aus dann
kommt da ein klein wenig geschrieben
drauf da möchte ich jetzt auch nicht so
viele nehmen wir einfach so einen kuchen
heber drehe meine platte und dann
verstreicht sich das ganz toll von ihnen
nach außen
es gibt übrigens silikon unterlagen die
könnte ich jetzt unter diese leicht
schaum platte legen dann wird die auf
dem holzbrett nicht verrutschen
dann kommt der zweite boten drauf noch
mal ein bisschen was drauf
[Musik]
und zwar rasch
kunst stand der deckel da kommt jetzt
ein bisschen gar nach oben drauf das
muss ich erstmal die erste schicht
machen und diese krümel binden
ich sehe ja da kuchen krümmel ziemlich
stark und damit die später eben nicht im
verband landen muss man eine erste
schicht machen die diese krümmel einfach
bindet
mit so einer tankkarte geht es natürlich
viel besser ich sehe dass krümel dann
auch immer mal wieder weg dann muss
einfach wieder ein bisschen kanal strom
wenn ihr dann guck mal so die erste
schicht habt kommt es so in den
kühlschrank und soll es mal fest werden
und statt die da gucken jetzt auf dieser
platte sitzt könnt ihr ihnen ganz gut
anheben könnten auf eure kuchen platte
setzen und einen kühlschrank stellen
nach etwa 15 minuten verwende ich meinen
kuchen jetzt weiter und möchte ihn jetzt
fertig streichen
dazu gebe ich etwas ganz auf meine zeit
hatte ich nehme das erst mal von der
platte dann gebe ich die garage
obendrauf und verstreicht die einmal
schön
rings herum und dann noch etwas am rand
[Musik]
und ihr seht ihr schüssel ist leer das
heißt die menge reicht mir wirklich ganz
genau für diese torten größe jetzt nehme
ich einfach die tankkarte und setzt die
hier im rechten winkel an
am rand also hier der rechte winkel hier
gehe so nah an die torte wie es geht
bis sich unten eben an diese skateboard
anstöße und zieht es einfach weg
also hier ansetzen tortenplatte drehen
im prinzip bewegt sich diese hand hier
gar nicht sondern nur die hier die dreht
nämlich die platte und einfach immer
darauf achten dass ihr im rechten winkel
habt nicht zuviel abziehen
wir haben jetzt ein loch reingemacht und
und wieder weg dann nehmt ihr euch am
besten eine palette wenn ihr so einen
nicht habt geht auch so etwas also
dieser kuchen heber noch mal
jetzt ziehe ich von außen mache ihnen
die creme vom rand mit
[Musik]
wenn ihr mit der oberfläche dann soweit
der regenzeit könnt ihr nochmal
detailkarten nehmen und den rand hier
oben noch mal glatt ab 10
[Musik]
die torte jetzt nochmal in den
kühlschrank und wenn sie dann schön fest
geworden ist nach etwa einer halben
stunde könnt ihr auch noch mal diese
kleinen unebenheiten hier schön
ausgleichen und dann ist so richtig
schön glatt beim bestreichen ist es ganz
wichtig dass die garage eben nicht mehr
zu kalt ist ich habe sie zwar einmal
durchgeführt wie ihr gesehen habt und so
lässt sie sich dann prima verarbeiten zu
bestreiten verwendet ihr am besten
paletten und teil karten mit denen habt
ihr einfach ein besseres gefühl und
können die torte richtig schön in einem
zug klatscht reichen
und weil es richtig perfekt haben möchte
besorgt sich eben noch so einen betrieb
hatte meine ist von ikea die habe ich
euch mal bereits in meinem bett video
gezeigt die kosten zur zwischen 7 und 8
euro wenn ich mich nicht falsch erinnere
und da könnt ihr einfach mit der einen
hand ortet regierung mit der anderen die
ganz abstreifen
ich werde jetzt den kuchen noch mal in
den kühlschrank stellen und weil das so
machen den vom land vorbereiten da habe
ich noch vom letzten mal übrig gehabt
also ich habe jetzt nicht extra vorderen
teil gestellt ihr müsst den vater und
jetzt richtig gut durchkneten des 25
minuten dann ist davon und auch nicht
richtig das haben wir damals viele das
problem das ich sagen der von dort wird
rissig das kann einfach daher dass sie
entweder zu wenig spielzeug benutzt habt
dann gebt ihr einfach noch ein paar
tropfen dazu und dann müsst ihr wirklich
richtig lange kneten dieser schön
geschmeidig ist und dann für den weiter
verwenden die deko werde ich später aus
blüten passte machen und auch mit etwas
spritzt das nur aber jetzt zeige ich
erst einmal wie ich die torte mit freund
und ein
der kern hier habe ich jetzt meinen
fondant ich hab den vier stunden aus dem
kühlschrank genommen da ist jetzt auf
zimmertemperatur gekommen bin ich weiß
dass ich den fondant benutzte dann nehme
ich ihn meistens auch schon am abend
vorher aus dem kühlschrank damit ein
fünftes kneten leichter geht jetzt nehme
ich mir hier etwas parallel treibt die
hände gut damit ein und auch etwas meine
arbeitsfläche und jetzt bitte von ganz
schön durchgeknetet und das müsst ihr
schon gut fünf minuten machen wenn ihr
merkt dass die hände etwas kleben dann
immer mal wieder mit palmen einreiben
[Musik]
und am besten spielt die palette mal mit
kurz mit heißem wasser ab man könnte das
sicher schön darüber streichen und die
oberfläche getrennt jetzt hätte ich die
arbeitsfläche noch mal gut ein
ihr könnt sie auch mit puderzucker
bestäuben
also wenn man von danza klebrig ist
bestätigt die arbeitsfläche lieber mit
puderzucker männer etwas dazu neigt
trocken zu sein dann mache ich das
lieber mit palmen
jetzt hätte ich auch noch meine 61 bzw
das ist ja gar kein nudelholz sondern in
ausbau stark den habe ich bei tupperware
gekauft und damit träume ich davon und
jetzt schön gleichmäßig
[Musik]
dann habe ich mir immer mal wieder auch
die torte darüber ob davon dann groß
genug ist das ist ja auf jeden fall
deswegen schneide ich hier das außen
einfach mal weg und dann rede ich mir
den funden einmal über meine torte
schneidet der überschuss außenrum weg
von streich das kurz mit den heldenplatz
und jetzt ganz wichtig hier am rand
wegziehen und in fondant andrücken also
da müsst ihr mit beiden händen arbeiten
die eine hand sieht denn von dort unten
weg und die andere hand drückt ihn an
den rand
[Musik]
bis runter dann nehme ich mir diesen
smoother die gibt es in online shops zu
kaufen
wie gesagt kaufe ich ja gerne bei taucht
in dekoration dieser und niederländische
onlineshop da drücke ich hier am rand
nochmal den von dort schön dran wenn
eure ghanas bereits zu trocken ist
dann müsst ihr den die torte vorher mit
etwas wasser befeuchten über meine
wahrheit noch schön flüssig jetzt
schneide ich hier den rand weg und das
bekommt jetzt beides moser zum einsatz
ein nach oben und dann über die ränder
und wie gesagt wenn eure torte zu
trocken ist dann müsst ihr sie mit
wasser befeuchten
damit der finanzplatz auflegt und damit
keine luftbläschen entstehen
[Musik]
und wenn ihr dann doch mal luftbläschen
habt so wie ich hier versucht ihr sie
nach unten hin weg zu streichen wenn es
nicht mehr geht müsste sie auf stechen
dann nehme ich mir einfach eine nadel
dazu stehe ich hier einmal zeitlich rein
und dann drücke ich die luft hier aus
dem loch heraus dann drüber gehen und
dann sieht man eigentlich nichts mehr
gut das war ein fehler von mir und hier
genauso hier etwas zeitlicher ein
stechen dann kann die luft durch das
loch entweichen und dann einfach drüber
streichen
das passiert eben wenn die torten
oberfläche nicht feucht genug war und
sich so die luft einlagert und wenn ihr
der meinung seid dass euer von dampf
dann glatt genug ist gibt ihr die torte
in den kühlschrank dann braucht ihr auch
keine angst haben von dem toten darf man
im kühlschrank lagern
solange die deko vorbereite werde ich
die torte wieder in den kühlschrank
stellen so kam sie nämlich dort etwas an
trocknen und ihr müsst auch keine sorge
haben von dem toten dürfen in den
kühlschrank der kühlschrank darf einfach
nicht zu feucht sein
aber das ist ja in der regel eigentlich
auch gar nicht ob meine deko mache ich
wie gesagt ausüben passte und albers
spritzt das sogar jederzeit da gibt es
natürlich auch schon in meinen uploads
dann ist ihr einfach mal danach schauen
und wenn ich koste ich als video antwort
da jetzt später machen zeitungsreporter
kommt von der bnn möchte ich die torte
mit meinem logo dekorieren
also hier mit diesem herzen und der
braune internet
und macht es einfach damit er später
auch was zum probiert hat und mache eben
für ein richtiges elliott orte ihr
könntet ihr natürlich so dekorieren wie
ihr möchtet
aber ich zeige mich jetzt einfach mal
wie ich das mache und zwar praktisch
[Musik]
dann gebe ich das auf meine schneide
unterlage legen eine schablone drauf und
dann benutze ich hier mein
schneidewerkzeug das sind so zwei rolle
und damit kann ich prima rundungen
ausschneiden
[Musik]
so las ich das jetzt einfach auf der
unterlage etwas an trocknen und fühle
mich so ran um die restliche co
[Musik]
ich möchte jetzt noch den rand hier
unten etwas verschönern dazu nämlich
pinkfarbene blüten passte werde sie
ausruhen und einen streifen schneiden
und den hier unten sauber anlegen damit
ich hier einfach einen sauberen
abschluss habe
wie sehe ich habe gerade fleißig gefärbt
deswegen sind meine finger jetzt so
verfärbt ihr könnt da auch handschuhe
anziehen dann bekommt die finger nicht
so viel ab
[Musik]
ich habe hier meinen streifen und ich
habe mich aus gemessen wie groß der
umfang einer torte ist da ist etwas so
so groß und ihr könnt euch das einfach
immer als hilfe nehmen einfach ein stück
stoff oder so ein banken geschenkband
einfach damit abmessen abschneiden und
dann habt ihr die den umfang einer torte
nehme ich einfach mein genial und
schneidet hier sauber einen streifen ab
das stelle ich mir das hier einmal
gewartet und dann einfach in der
gewünschten breite ich möchte sitz in
etwa so breit haben zum zentimeter
dann nehme ich mir meine torte und
streicht dem rand hier unten mit kleber
ich habe euch in meinen pinguin video
bereits erklärt wie man zucker kleber
herstellt mann müsst ihr einfach mal
reinschauen
dann nehme ich vorsichtig sind streifen
hier hoch gelegt den außen rum und dann
fange ich hier an ihn anzuklagen
[Musik]
hier seht ihr dass ich immer etwas
großzügiger messe man weiß ja nie
deswegen lieber ein stück abschneiden an
dem stück dann später sind wir nicht zu
haben und hier in diesen kleinen spalt
kommt auch etwas kleber damit sich das
ende gut verbindet dann nehme ich mir
hier jetzt noch einen streifen und
weißer streifen herstellen oder streifen
hat in etwa die gleiche breite wie das
band das schneide ich mir jetzt in sechs
zentimeter lange stücke drehe ich sie um
ich markiere mir dann mal geht immer
noch die mitte und da kommt jetzt noch
ein bisschen zucker paper drauf und dann
braucht ihr so strohhalm den schneide
ich mir jetzt dann nehme ich mir so zwei
stroh helmchen lebte hier an den rand
und klappt die schleife von außen nach
innen ein nutzen muss jedoch ein messer
und dieses stroh helmchen hilft einfach
dabei dass die schleife schön plastisch
wird und nicht flach und damit die
schleife auch garantiert gut aussieht
wird hier jetzt noch in streifen in der
mitte den schneide ich mir jetzt hier
ganz einfach aus ganz dünn
dann kommt hier etwas kleber in die
mitte und dann bitte streifen hier
einmal drüber gelegt
etwas rein gedrückt und dann
verschwinden die enden einfach auf der
rückseite wenn die schleifen dann soweit
sind klebe ich sie an den rand meiner
torte und zuerst bekleben immer hier
diese stelle an der ich die zahl
zusammen gefügt habe es nur mit etwas
kleber an drücken und dann könnt ihr den
strohhalm auch vorsichtig entfernen und
die schleife einfach in form legen die
nächste schleifen mache ich direkt
gegenüber
[Musik]
jetzt möchte ich meine torte fertig
stellen ich jetzt hier
diese blüten passten deko und hier habe
ich mir etwas eiweiß spritztour
hergestellt in weiß und pink das rezept
dazu gibt es in meinem hotel atx video
das werde ich euch unten als video
antwort posten
jetzt möchte ich dieses herz auf meine
torte auf menge
[Musik]
und jetzt könnt ihr das einfach mit
bisschen zucker klever ankleben
[Musik]
jetzt möchte ich hier mit einem
schriftzug machen ich probiert es mal
vorher hier auf einem deckel aus wie ihr
sehen könnt lässt sich das super
verarbeiten
[Musik]
fertig und kann wieder im kühlschrank
etwas ausruhen
die torte ist es etwa drei bis vier tage
haltbar
deswegen ist sie auch ganz gut
vorzubereiten und dann könnt ihr euch
wie gesagt die zeit schön einteilen
könnte jeden tag ein bisschen dran
arbeiten und dann ist es auch nicht ganz
so anstrengend und macht natürlich spaß
jetzt wünsche ich euch viel spaß beim
nachbacken wünsche euch einen guten
appetit und vergesst auch keine fahnen
nächste woche dienstag um 15 uhr 15 zdf
einzuschalten und uns die daumen zu
drücken da werde ich dann mit meiner
freundin bei den topf der regeln
antreten und bin schon ganz gespannt was
er dazu sagen werdet dann freue ich mich
aus normalen und das war's
[Musik]
super jetzt kann ich anfangen wenigen
zutaten brauchen wir